counseling cart gonna get some icecream
gonna stuff it up gonna let it I've been
researching some of the craziest donuts
in New York City and I noticed that a
new place is opening up right now just a
few blocks away from the BuzzFeed office
they have ice cream stuff doing us and
they look pretty crazy so I decided I
have to try it for myself and I'm going
to bring along two co-workers and we're
gonna do a little taste test
alright we're here at stuff ice cream
and two of my co-workers and we're gonna
taste some ice cream ice cream is two
desserts combined into one it's donuts a
nitrogen can't get better than that we
wanted to come up with a name that
sounded like a real word so it's sort of
like a hybrid of ice cream and stuff so
we took the cream from ice cream and
stuff gonna put it together
tella crumb this is my favorite part of
the donuts which is glazing it because
this adds a nice shiny coating
to all the donuts we'll cut these in
half and we'll put a scoop of ice cream
in between and afterwards we have a
secret little heating process then we
sprinkle some toppings on you're gonna
have fruity pebbles and every bite that
you take will throw on some more
toppings right before we serve it there
you go yeah via cruft not many people
have come yet because it's literally
just opening so
like food bloggers and influencers I'm
not food blog or a critic or an expert
but I sure know how to eat food so
that's where I'm judging based off I
will second that I know food I like food
so I can talk about food
bring on the crafts Oh like this is too
pretty for me to eat I do glamorous
shopping in the mall how do you eat then
maybe we just take it out like a Stan
Lee yeah yeah nice play oh baby turtle
Cheers at first bite the donut hits you
right
another thing the glaze goes hey but
then the ice cream is like sis you paint
with me didn't you so then the ice cream
takes over what kind of ice cream is so
the green is green tea and then we have
Thai iced tea and then we have a coat of
Cap'n Crunch oh oh wait convinced milk
boom boom BAM this is white chocolate
lavender I know it looks like strawberry
or bubblegum or something but it is
chocolatey and it's delicious so what
I'm working with we got a little rocky
road right here I this blue stuff with
blue goodness is called cookie monster
cookies and green and then we got a
little coconut frosting toasted coconut
flakes and some
syrup on it and it is muted and you
think like a donut that would be like oh
my gosh this is gonna be a sugar attack
but this donut it's like it's not
perfectly glazed it's not too sweet
I'm lactose intolerant but not today
delicious you're gonna be partying so
much on the way back I seen none sorry
in advance for me the craziest thing is
how the donut stays warm in my hole like
it's not mixing together then you could
eat it for breakfast right because
doughnuts are breakfast lunch and dinner
give me a bathroom break in the mid of
the night on its own maybe at the end of
your meal and like you run your bread
through the plate ie you're running
through the ice cream oh it's so good
I'll get off the day before officially
stop and think we can use the napkin
[Music]